a U.S Navy ship has taken more than a
hundred U.S citizens away from the
violence in Sudan but many more are
still waiting to be rescued the evacuees
left the African nation's capital city
on Friday and drove hundreds of miles by
bus to the Red Sea where the ship took
them to Jeddah Saudi Arabia
inocencio is there Ramey good morning
good morning Michelle that's right this
is the U.S naval ship Brunswick right
behind me and this is the one that
traveled overnight through the night
carrying these Americans and many others
crossing the Red Sea a 200 Mile Stretch
something like 12 hours The Americans on
board and so many others finally safe
after a harrowing Journey
inside
celebration and relief for more than 300
evacuees most from the U.S others from
at least 16 other nations escaping this
more than two weeks of chaos Sudan's
military and biggest paramilitary block
fighting for power
upended Vehicles rubblestroon roads The
New Normal
after their dangerous drive from the
capital Khartoum to Port Sudan the
Americans we spoke to said that they
were stuck in that port for another 24
hours
Muhammad faraj is from Brooklyn New York
he said the U.S embassy did a good job
but email access was spotty thank God
the ones we did get we used it and we're
here eleven-year-old norvivi said she
was exhausted and afraid it was very
scary because I was scared of the army I
feel relieved I feel safe you know I
feel way better than how I felt in Sudan
how did you feel in Sudan terrified
actually like scary scary to hear
gunshots outside of your house my last
Khalid is from Queens New York I'm just
seeing like
he's flying straight back to the United
States you're taking off now
I feel relieved like alhamdulillah I'm
happy
tragically not every American who wanted
to flee made it this American doctor
based in Iowa City was stabbed to death
the day he and his family decided to
leave
another unidentified American with ties
to Denver was killed in crossfire
overnight more anxious people crowded
Port Sudan waiting for the next
transport to take them and their
families away from a country on the edge
of Civil War
and this ship will not be the end of
American evacuations from Sudan CBS News
has now learned that a new Convoy of
eight buses with Americans on board that
has arrived in Port Sudan Nate this is
not over
those that are there and those that are
evacuating Remy and asinci on Saudi
Arabia thank you